cioè ci poteva paravia di video da qua
non andarlo a questo è a mio zio
mamma mia brava hai visto quanto come
investimento bravo basta adesso andiamo
i tuoi scritti dicono ci sta
abbandonando non viene più alle fiere
alle fiere non sanno cosa c'è dietro non
sanno non sanno tanto sai cosa stiamo
mondo a farlo lo sai già ospitata
ricordi molto bene me lo ricordo
benissimo ricordi io ma ricordo mi
ricordo cominciamo
si comincia si comincia però aspettiamo
farti parlare reactions reaction
reaction basta costato è così a rieti
questa è successo in live questi inizia
abilità sono fortissimi sono fortissimi
e riusciamo a prendere un gol
quindi siamo sotto di 1 e poi alla fine
siamo sotto di 22 ore 21 30 erano for
abbiamo preso due gol e sono pochi che
non ho imparata riparto miracolosamente
gol quindi va bene mancano tredici
secondi alla fine e questi hanno
fortissimi broker ha quindi già ce l'hai
affidati cioè non hai non ha idea non ce
l'hai 13 secondi che ansia
oddio bru
però aspetta ne mancano due come 3 2 ma
mancano due secondi da noi non ha idea
dei sventare talmente paura al caso a 2
a 0 stop blu erano fortissimi
mamma mia meglio che stupido quel tipo
stato sciopero erano fortissimi e allora
l'ora
adesso io sono il trucco ma perché sei
lavoro ultima richiesta pertanto perché
so che la mia bella che cosa col corpo a
corpo
qual è la modalità corpo a corpo vince
meglio di otto livello casuale
ab pompiere e l'altro viene altro che
rispetti non mi ricordo neanche io mi
ricordo dai partiamo così io sono il
pompiere ma siamo contro no così come
scusa un governo allora io sono anche
più grosso quindi sono più facili da
afferrare
madonna non mi ricordo neanche visto nei
tasti sto facendo però non mi ricordi
tasti numerale o cose
io però si grossa così come i vecchi al
cantiere sogni e roma su quale collega
il teatro non hai vinto con adesso parte
su il messico non mi ricordi tassi ma
quali sono r b davanti non ha sbagliato
il tastino succede è la la pallamano
aspetta aspetta
stiamo facendo skydiving ma che adora
studiata mai fatto no neanch'io
intanto il cappello ma
come pareggio parmareggio ma dai
maledizione are dead redemption mogol
no non è vero non è vero però cosa sta
succedendo
ma che succede se il pelato nell'ultimo
episodio vi dicevo solo io come è
possibile non è possibile è vinta è
possibile donna si no sì parente sei
caduto prima tu non è giusto che anche
prima
madonna
mica che testate blog lo le pale sono
vivo no dai
mi hai dato una testata qua ci sta al
replay mai la serata è stata fortissima
non è possibile siamo 30 come l'ultimo
da licio solo io
se adesso gioco premia chi fa punti di
far solo lui cioè una killing spree ogni
personaggio c'è una caratteristica
persone tra passera mica la metro che
una donna dai tipo matrix non passa però
tanto tempo e così rimane però non
capisco bene io non ho mai detto che
c'era la luce di fatti che succede e
basta
sì sì sì e si vince tanto tempo per
passare st m barca era nel passato nel
secondo poi non puoi non a chi aspetta
chi è
si no non posso crederci non sarà che
incredibile ci hai visto veramente
impegnando tantissimo
com'è possibile l'ultima volta ti sei
fatto uccidere tutte le volte come
possibile 50 o di questo ricordo bene
partiamo subito no brother non sono vivo
come si sono un po spider man
oddio non vedo non vedo che sono io ok
tu stai correndo la rete questa è una
gara a chi rimane attaccato bene sì sì
sì va bene cammino lo fa perché perché
sono tutte ben diversa dall altra volta
l'unica che avevamo fatto
ho vinto io passano già attrezzato io no
cosa che avevi bisogno di aiuto però aia
dove se non hanno che sta succedendo
ok non riesco a salire 9 paga a salire
non sale ma il mio personaggio non sa
ieri con sale no però aspettiamo una
scarico merci con si fa per dire no non
lo aspetta una no no no io vi sono e
sono allibito 6 allibito perché non hai
tu questo canale io sono costi dovrebbe
essere il contrario cioè raga andate a
vedere l'altra volta vincevo solo io non
è possibile è impossibile una piccola
mori da ice mi aggrappo se vinci
pareggio dai dati devi arrivare a te le
manca una me ne manca uno mica viste
devo fare nel sette di fila perché in
teoria infatti design questo e un
microfono ge in chiave che ti sto
cappello madonna che te lo infilo perché
sì sì no no bar enoteche testata data a
questa partita non finirà mai è tratto
il bello che sono tranquilli per per un
po e poi signora
ma perché io volo eccolo comunque non mi
piace il personaggio è corto di
personale secondo me oddio no no no no
perché se pensate che paura queste e
basta però non riesco a fatti uscire se
non è vero
i sei appeso a cosa cos'era
e vabbè spider man 38 ho perso mi bravo
nell upper ecco qui la rivincita allora
d'avvio cambio personalità che facciamo
uno a quattro anni la meta di prima ok
perché abbiamo personaggio perché questo
è il colore che si cambiano bene la vera
che io sono quello a destra
lui è quello a sinistra a questo salta
ancora di meno di voli prima quindi
potrebbe essere un problema solo la
testata funziona molto bene o no no dopo
di stordire la testata di far perdere i
sensi per un attimo si perpetua una gran
dama provolo darti una mano però ci sono
riusciti
va bene tre a zero il sole stranissimo
vinci sempre non crederci sempre dice la
via di un capisco però il peso a puoi
fare questa cosa si beh è stata
utilissima figli a perché si ci mette un
po ad annegare va bene
mi sono divertito è stato del 61 61
cristiano ronaldo è un po io quando
giocavo a calcio un po la stessa va bene
ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto il video
ringrazio giampiero per aver partecipato
lascio il suo canale instagram pista con
canalis chi sta in descrizione analista
non si diceva bechis ne avrà come sai
servito è piaciuto alciato momento è un
mi piace anche risorsa che come inedito
descrizione sono formati siete vi
giriamo al prossimo spintone o o
qualsiasi cosa farlo insieme
non mi tirare d'estate non a voi fare a
ok certo molto ambigua questo modo che i
ragazzi
[Musica]